good morning Millennials happy Friday we
made it here
finally in a strange twist of events
thanks to hurricane Florence we are now
joined by Darren carp sorry for the
delay but Darren is a busy woman I am so
sorry for the delay I apologize claudia
was texting me yesterday I was like I
can't get out of this thing I was
actually doing a vo record for my new
Auto Trader commercial which is coming
out I think in the next two weeks I
don't think you understand how much I
love your auto trip how much Zach loves
you that's his opinion I care about you
ever came on the show when it was the
old show and then I told that you were
coming in he was he was like you have to
ask her about the commercial like he
thinks it's so good and so do I that's
amazing and they're all so good can you
give us like a little storyboard for
this next one this next one is
definitely me teasing Andy a lot more
and I think it's the funnier I've been
at this would be my third one and I
think it's the funniest of them there's
sculptures involved I'll put it that way
it's very good I'm so excited and for
anyone who's like first time watching
the toast and doesn't know who you are
and yes I didn't you miss what's
necessary but is about to be pleased
your bio my name is Darren Karp you can
follow me on social media at carpe
Darren I host martinis and murder on
oxygen
I do bravotv.com web series but my most
important main role is I'm Andy Cohen's
assistant at Bravo so I I have a little
Bravo gossip and all the time that's a
lot oh and you're so like good at
telling us a lot and feeling like we're
in the know but also like being
professional keeping your job and that's
the hardest part of my job I'm sure yeah
I like can't get into trouble sorry I
tote the line doesn't go unnoticed yes
well you know because I think don't keep
it juicy and also like you know the
people upstairs are happy I'm trying to
give the people what they want to know
Jackie you are gonna get if anyone's
gonna get a view it's the morning toast
he meant to bed oh it's the morning
toast
so we are so happy that you're here we
have feel great show for you today
anyone who is affected by hurricane
Florence right now we are thinking of
you I'm sorry
stay safe if you're traveling stay safe
and I mean Claudia is she was rerouted
she had to move her whole trip because
going to Puerto Rico right now like it
doesn't make a lot of sense
Coran less you just like want to stay
indoors and like hunker down that
doesn't seem like a Claudia thing to
want to do no it doesn't seem
to vacation like might as well stay here
and hunker down by the way can I just
say a major FOMO about camp toast
it looked so fun it was so late they
would have loved it do you ever go to
camp yeah I went to camp when I was like
okay cuz like there were some people
with like there's two people with
there's two types of people in this
world right people who went to camp and
just want more camp in their life people
who have never really experienced camp
who like can't even wrap their heads
around what it actually like what it is
and like that level of just like fun
camaraderie that you don't have anywhere
else in this world either color war and
not I don't mean this in like a bad way
but like color Wars they're so fun and
like Red Rover and capture the flag like
that's what camp is all about in major
FOMO for me hell their war was like
really intense like I think some people
like have PTSD like I just like I look
back on in and like like Hitsville and
like my team technically lost but I
think we had more fun that's really what
I'm really like when I'm in charge like
I'm I really try to like just keep
everyone happy like no one has to play
they don't want to play like I'm it's
very hard to toe the line of like we
have to win but I don't want people like
to be uncomfortable were there any men
there yes there were three men they
added so much value of course they did
they oh my god they were amazing and
they were also so good at like capture
the flag and great how do you had two of
them on her team like that was a little
unfair but um it's fine it seems like it
you're really athletic I am I thought ik
I played soccer I think most of my life
if you come to campus I'm on your team
you're on my team yeah done we don't
even need any man I'm going to be like
the resident man on your team Jackie and
not yes strength of three men over here
yes we're actually in the process of
planning kam toast to now I'm like it's
in a while it won't be till Memorial Day
weekend okay so we're just so excited
that we just want to have everything in
place let everyone like know when it is
plan to get their tickets and just like
then have six months or I can't count
but however long to like just look
forward to it do we know where it is
next year it's the same place same exact
place Poconos which was perfect perfect
and like oh my god it was just so fun
and obviously yeah anyways without
further ado we are gonna get into the
Fast Five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and then we're
gonna just do Q&A with Darren talk about
all things Bravo everything that's
airing right now everything that happens
you were last here right and we're just
gonna get like the total team Carol
can't I can't
I shed it's just it's also capable get
to it yeah okay okay
our first story and also you know what
not a lot of Sudbury news happening
yesterday and I'm grateful because now
we can talk about some real stuff yeah
let's get into like the hard news Jackie
we're getting into hard news we're
getting into weather we're getting into
a little bit of politics today just
because this is the Cynthia Nixon of it
all we have some crossover fare okay
okay like a popcorn actually getting
into some fitness news and some legal
news whoa okay okay guys gird your loins
this is actually gonna be really heavy
really heavy for a Friday
first up hurricane Florence makes
landfall as torrential rains battered
the coast hurricane Florence made
landfall Friday morning just east of
Wilmington North Carolina where it
brought a life-threatening storm surge
that pushed water inland for miles
pounding rains and powerful winds that
battered buildings in its path the
category 1 hurricane was a Mac with
maximum winds of 90 miles per hour and
dumping 3 inches of rain in an hour
made landfall at 7:15 a.m. near
Wrightsville Beach according to the
National Hurricane Center more than 60
people had to be pulled from a
collapsing Motel at the height of the
storm and many more who were to defied
evacuation orders were hoping to be
rescued
the powerful storm inundated coastal
streets and left tens of thousands
without power forecasters said quote
catastrophic freshwater flooding was
expected along waterways from far from
the coast of the Carolinas this is so so
crazy and just I hope everyone and I
hope all the animals are okay well
that's it's like always the hardest I
mean granted yes people like I don't
want anything to happen but just there's
something there just so helpless they're
so innocent and watching them you know
those commercials where it's like if you
give 50 cents a day or whatever I can't
watch the animals yeah right exactly
like a dog can eat for a week I can't
watch the like the animal ones I can
watch the human ones that's sad right
I'm like that is sad but actually no the
animal ones I feel like we're at a point
now where they're just like they're so
overdone we're yeah a little too
dramatic when they show them like in the
cages and mean skin like that I can no I
can't and the Yulin dog meat festival
can no no no no but I thought I thought
they were gonna get like thirty inches
of rain there two and a half feet of
rain
in the Carolinas I don't think we're
filming southern charm yet so think
about really now because I'm pretty sure
that my that the showrunner who's like
my very good friend had to evacuate and
I think she's in Georgia right now I
kind of waiting out the storm before
that we even start to film so yeah I
guess we're like Justin they usually
start filming in the fall everyone has
their riding boots out and their their
Patagonia best rate of everyone has to
have a Patagonia vest right I almost
want to bail out to be a cast member if
you don't have a Patagonia best a barber
jacket Louie Vuitton luggage and riding
boots oh I was gonna say in boat shoes I
feel like that's also yeah for the men
for the and a custom pillow by Craig yes
now the criteria which Andy has in his
office and I love it's like my favorite
piece of pop culture art that Andy has
has like crabs on it oh that's your
favorite thing like more than them bunny
yeah even more than but now the bunny
has a ball gag on it so it really fits
my oh yeah demo I really like Arctic
Tern the last reunion the ball gag I
mean watching a baby toy I have the most
sexual like visceral sexual toy that you
can imagine on it and on my boss's set
is great
yeah that's Bravo uh anyways this
hurricane I hope a lot of people have
activated I saw last night that someone
that people were encouraging other
people to write their name and their
phone number on the belly of their dogs
so that if they do get lost and when I
first thought I was like who is branding
these dogs right then I was like oh that
actually makes a lot of sense like if
the dog he's wandering total I mean it
or I guess he could also just have a tag
but or a collar yeah or like a lot of
people do those GPS chips now which is
actually very smart for your animal but
like it's just what do you do I mean if
you're told to evacuate even if you're
told to evacuate your apartment in
Manhattan what do you what do you take
whoa what do you think what are the
three things you grabbed let's say you
have five make up five minutes you have
five minutes what are you grabbing I
feel like in five minutes I go I don't
grab any I wouldn't I wouldn't rob
anything I just run if it's really that
dire there's nothing like that important
actually would you grab Zack if you
sleeping okay
yeah come on you like anything anything
that I have it's like really like
sentimental that it yeah that can't be
replaced right I mean something of value
but that could just be inherent value or
it could be like a childhood heirloom
right whatever your
maybe I just like put on my Sunday best
you would be like dressed to the nines
you having all my shoes I'm stuffed
purses and purses and purses but it's
like yeah I would only take clothes
though yeah let me close the door well I
don't really have a photo album in my
apartment like my parents house oh my
god and Zach it always makes funny like
I really don't have any pictures in the
apartment yet yeah like I mean he moved
like six months ago but he's like such a
photos person and I'm like not not a I
mean actually I'm a photos person but
I'm not a pic photo frame person I don't
know it's just like I feel like you
acquire those over time you don't like
set out I'm gonna do my picture frames
well great because then it's all gonna
be from like one time period why do you
want to like grow that collection over
time you like gifts a photo right a nice
frame you do a you do a mere mere photo
booth out a wedding and looking good
exactly a couple yeah I'd actually
probably take books like books that
meant a lot to me that I've had since
forever I have like a couple first
editions of my favorite novels I take
that does that make me lay him no that's
actually like a way better answer then
most people would give like because
anything that's like material is
material what books are technically
material items but they have so much
meaning right so much meaning yeah no
I'm not like an e-book like I read
actual books that's that's actually
really good answer you're a good person
thank you I would also just bring some
like toiletries and essentials like
moisturizer a toothbrush toothbrush he
key got it your I mean as we know your
breath has to be fresh right as you know
it really does like that's the only
thing I could really make it worth
except my breath is like never fresh
because I'm always on a diet but um is
that true like if you're not eating like
if you don't either trying to dye it why
do you have bad breath acidity in the
stomach there's two things one for
people that go on like Tito
going into Quito or Atkins which is what
I do most of the time going into ketosis
like gives you bad breath it's like a
thing it's like just because of their
like acidity in your cycles yeah were
the things that you're eating it's like
because they're not cute like you're
eating tuna fish cheese well that's
right like that's not a recipe for
success and then I think for people who
are dieting it's like almost like if you
go for like hours without eating it's
like your breath your breath tastes
stale almost like when you wake up in
the morning and it's been 12 hours it
ten hours since you last brushed your
teeth you have any fair ok fair so gum
gum how to thrush Listerine strips
Atkins is no car
Atkins no carbs keto was like Atkins
re-branded I guess like Atkins has a bad
rap and now people just say keto but
it's really the same thing
what is it it was from Aikido and paleo
I mean we're really going off on yeah
like I just figure like fruits
vegetables and like but act maybe paleo
has a lot of fruits more fruits and
vegetables but Atkins like technically
fruits fruits have a lot of carbs right
bananas a car right so you really don't
eat fruit on keto wear Atkins and go
bunny some vegetables but like not a lot
they also have carbs and those are the
car the only carbs you should be eating
in the day like you got 20 carbs a day
during when you start out when you're
being like really good and that's really
for like lettuce and vegetables and
things that you need to like eat got it
do you have a cheat day I have like a
cheat month week like I'm always
laughing on but now I've restarted since
camp toast and I'm really trying to like
do a hard month hardcore okay like
before from Camp toast and Labor Day
before it I was like terrible so I don't
ever feel like deprived because when I'm
not on it I eat everything
what everything your tiny oh my god no I
literally have the biggest appetite and
then it's like because sometimes I'm so
good in life it's like oh well if I
don't need this now I'm never gonna have
a chance to right so I don't I don't
feel like a deprived person because I
really indulge when I indulge right but
you can't even have toast a bad kids no
you cannot okay so we're gonna have to
rerun the entire show now write this
well actually or I could just have a
drink right okay yeah the morning drink
yes card about keto is at most alcohols
no carbs like vodka tequila you could
literally chunk as much as you want wine
has like a carb or two per glass but
like that's not gonna kill you yeah it's
like the sugar really gets it it's not
like like you don't have to stop
drinking yeah that's that's fair that's
why cheats you never so Cheech yeah
she's always like tequila soda tequila
soda yes that's why zero carbs like she
could technically drink as much as you
want yeah she does my friend she says hi
Chi Chi Chi Chi um anyways so this
hurricane is blowing through I just hope
that it's like the best it could be
given dire circumstances you don't know
like totally how everything's gonna land
I'm hopeful that they gave enough
warning for people to evacuate because I
feel like we've known about this at
least for a week now yeah but a lot of
people don't evacuate and and I'm
one-handed kind of understand that
because you're like I'm gonna hunker
down in my house this is where I'm
comfortable this is right have the other
part of me is like your life is more
important than anything else and you
don't want to be effed like at the end
of the day when it hits and you can't
border your windows what are you doing
like get out now just be safe it's like
whether you're in your house or not your
house is still gonna you can't save your
house right you can't the houses coming
down like it's coming down whether
you're in it or you you've evacuated
yeah and it's also probably a good idea
never to buy property on water like as a
general rule what that it's so beautiful
I agree rent property never owned
property on water it's just like not a
financial insurance which is
astronomical and even when you do like
it yeah of course it has to be it has to
be astronomical because when that
happens like you have to pay all these
high premiums because then everything is
gonna get completely wiped out
so and then you rebuild and it happens
again so it's it's just not a
financially sound investment if we're
getting deep on Friday sometimes the
insurance companies can [ __ ] you like in
now you see me command you have to have
a group of magicians to come and steal
all your money back
a group of magicians do that yes have
you seen that you see me [ __ ] everyone
with Katrina insurance and so they took
all of his money but it's like that that
happens it's like that's a thing that
occurred okay but what about property on
the water and not hurricane impacted
areas like cuz in New York we don't see
a lot of hurricanes aside from Sandy
right okay it's a rarity so you would
you recommend investing in waterfront
properties in New York I mean yeah I
would LinkedIn's that's a good
investment it's a great investment but
when something like during sandy I don't
know how those properties manage like I
just I just I just find that it's
probably better to rent so that way
you're not responsible for any of the
heirlooms or damage that gets rude your
main property should never be waterfront
property okay just I know you're gonna
wind up and you're gonna buy me a
waterfront property right everything
about it and now I just have to like
change my plan just like yeah we could
go inland get me something else
you know I mean like understand think
about something else really I'm glad we
had this conversation that would be just
a total waste
it would really would be also is crazy
how last year southern term Savannah was
filming during the hurricane yes and
like
seeing them all evacuate think that was
so crazy it's very scary I'm er not
filming right now are they mmm it
doesn't seem right I don't just think so
no I don't think so and I don't think
southern charm original Charleston has
started yet thank God I'm so ready for
it though like there's been so much
offseason drama there's a lot going on
and like actually not good drama either
no but Ashley Jacobs has been China from
this show which I don't know if you know
means we no longer speak about her
because it's just too annoying
yes she's blacklisted right that's what
happened with blac Chyna like we could
no longer just talk about in her anymore
like during the Rob in China when she
showed us her for China before noon and
we were just like we're talking mad at
every single day and we're like it's
just we've reached peak China right so
no more China
no more China so that anyone else after
that who was getting like that we now
they are China yeah
so Ashley Jacobs has been charted okay
but I've been seeing like conflicting
things from all these like a fake news
sites I don't know what to believe but
either her and Thomas have broken up or
they're engaged what those are the two
options those are the two options but it
kind of makes perfect right those are
the few when watching the show this
season it's like wow they either need to
break up or getting each so right it's
and now it's been like eight months
since that so I hope they either broke
up or gotta gate what do you hope
happens for the sake of the show okay
well actually no it's I'm conflicted
because for the sake of the show I hope
they got engaged for the sake of Kathryn
I hope they broke up because she
indicator has to see that woman ever but
given everything that's going on like
legally with Thomas I think Kathryn
could get full custody in which case
Thomas can date whoever he chooses amen
it's honestly about the kids for me like
I want Catherine to be a very good
healthy position but like and Thomas and
Ashley aren't even gonna be on the show
anyway no so I don't give no I don't I
mean I don't as long as there's no
endangerment of the children then go be
or ralph whatever you want to go do go
buy waterfront property for all I care
totally no so if they're gonna be gonna
try I don't give a hoot what they do
yeah hence the China hang W team work
now we're officially Chinese she's no I
love China yeah anyways we're gonna get
to all Bravo stuff once we just get
through the news of the day yeah the
second story is really sort of wild
Julie Chen returns to Big Brother saying
quote I'm Julie
ten Moonves which you don't think is a
big deal but Julie Chen hosts Big
Brother every night she signs off from
outside the Big Brother house I'm Julie
Chen and last night after everything
that's happened with Leslie Moonves she
said from outside the Big Brother house
I'm Julie Chen Moonves good night that's
big that's big that is a statement that
she is she has drawn the line in the
sand and she's known as Julie Chen like
no one ever has said I've never even
heard her referred to as like mrs.
Moonves or Julie Chen you invest ever in
my entire television career so for her
to kind of say that it she's standing by
her man she is standing by her man which
is just like this might not be the time
like maybe be Julie Chen Moonves when
like he's at the top of the world and
like the head of CBS like now but so
she's sticking by him I don't I mean I
think that's Claudia's trying to get my
attention in the comments like what was
she doing and if you wanna hear Claudia
okay Claudia what do you want me to see
like literally I'm scrolling up cuz she
keeps saying get her attention get her
attention
what is that any good this better be
good can you not hear me did I do
something no we'll see okay we'll see
she knows now that I'm looking but
anyways quality China movement and
Claudia like Julie Chen Moonves like we
this is important stuff interruption as
Claudia like you're not here like we
don't you know what I mean like I'm
taking over today no totally come on no
but like I really hope whatever I'm like
I've stalled the show now for it is good
I hope it's just like a really fun emoji
better there's a text read comments look
at YouTube I am oh my god this is so
very now she's now deliberately
sabotaging you know but it's like I've
been reading I'm reading and by there is
a short delay but like by now she knows
no she knows I'm looking at her oh my
god I can't okay I really can't like
Julie Julie tendon is numb at all like
we have things to get to there's a lot
of things to say though about this
because it's like not to get a little
deep but like Hillary Clinton stuck by
Bill Clinton when the whole Monica
Lewinsky thing came out right and now
it's me too it's 20 30 years later so it
feels like different when you stand by
your man you know what I mean like
there's different stigmas by it and
listen they've had a very long
relationship
I'm sure that they're very happy
together for her to stick by him you
know says to me a lot about how she
feels about the allegations but I'm very
hesitant to sort of judge her for
sticking by him or saying no to him
either way because there's so much
details in a marriage that no one really
knows how a marriage plus a business
relationship like right also her boss
and like she wrote she rose the ranks
you guys like she's hosting Big Brother
which I don't watch but millions of
people my God my mom's obsessed with it
and really sit through it for an entire
week she was like we're watching it
tonight I think you enjoy it well you
know what I can kind of get into any TV
show as long as I commit to it I did
enjoy it I mean I watch it when it first
came out I was young so I don't even
know how long ago that was 15 years ago
I did enjoy it it's interesting to see
the characters and well they're they're
character traits the people that are on
the show because they're not playing
their parts they're playing themselves
yeah and it's like at a certain point
you can like try and be good for TV but
when you're on the live feed 24/7 like
you well that's what's interesting your
sounds like or else you're gonna caught
in a lie you're just gonna be like oh
yeah I'm not left-handed I'm
right-handed
like I'm gonna keep this trend going I
don't understand how you win cuz I don't
understand how you play the game do you
make everyone like you or do you make
only certain people like you I guess I
just don't know how to win right and I
think none of them do it's like just
timing luck and right luck of the draw
like what's gonna happen this week and
that's it right yeah there's a lot of
there's a lot of nuances I was just like
okay let me just see all these people
interact interesting
yeah audio this is OKC news one that I
have a stick around my shoe which I do
because they're new and - well she's
doing the Lord's work okay she caught
you on that like Ramona - yeah but they
are I'm not pretending like they're not
new but I'm also not trying to return
them so let's see did I buy my both you
ever have my shoes rolled got him Wow
nice um and - she can't get les Moonves
stuck out of her head she said she was
packing last night for two to three
hours and all she could think is Les
Moonves and I have to be honest like
yeah so did I I was like laying in bed
it's a name it just has like rhythm to
it let's move is let's move s yeah it's
like a band yeah yeah like les
Moonves but I I mean yes you can't judge
someone for sticking by their man but we
were talking about this before the show
and like I feel like most women in this
situation they initially distance some
distance themselves and then when it
dies down they get they it turns out
they never got divorced and they're
right together through Gena Chapman
Harvey Weinstein I don't know where
they're at now and I don't think things
will ever die down with Harvey Weinstein
so I think it really is over for them if
she ever if she wants her career and
like I was shopping for dresses and
Marchesa was very much there and very
much new so she does want a career right
so she has to separate herself from from
the big Harvey well yeah I guess Julie
Chen Moonves is taking the opposite
approach and maybe it just makes sense
to kind of in their marriage let's see
how the like let's see where the
dominoes fall here and let's wait till
everything happens and then we can kind
of decide what to do with our marriage
we don't know what's happening behind
closed doors and we don't know what she
believes or what she heard or what's
true or what's not so I'm just kind of
like taking a step back and hoping that
Julie and she seems like such a
competent smart funny capable woman she
I don't know her like truly every time I
have ever seen or met her she has been
nothing but utterly professional and
seems like a honestly like a lovely
woman I have I've never heard anything
really met her I've met her she's been
on the show I've never had anything I've
never heard anything bad about her but
so I don't know what happens behind
closed doors I can only imagine she's
smart enough to make the right decision
for her I understand so very piecey
answer is a very piecey answer and you
know what I don't really watch a lot of
stuff on CBS so yeah maybe there I don't
really know these people and it doesn't
affect my life but it's affecting the
top five stories of the day it is yes
and it's affecting my phone
notifications all I get is like Les
Moonves Les Moonves Les Moonves well
like and like Jeff Fager from 60 minutes
at CBS now is out too so it's like CBS
itself is having a lot of issues right
now yeah yeah okay everyone I'm done
looking at the comments the stickers off
my shoe Les Moonves has been said now
treat if you drank every time we said
Les Moonves like that'd be a great
drinking go to the hospital yeah you're
already dead you've already died sorry
just like his career but one more nice
Jackie Les Moonves yeah yeah I never
know when it's gonna come up again right
it sucks anyways our third story a
little political news since
Nexen lost its political it's it's sex
in the city it's pop culture political
yeah is Cynthia Nixon loses Democratic
primary for New York Governor the
results of New York's Democratic primary
are in Cynthia Nixon has lost to the
sitting governor of New York Andrew
Cuomo around 10:45 p.m. Eastern Time two
hours after the polls closed Nixon
emerged at a Mediterranean lounge in
Brooklyn as jay-z song Empire State of
Mind played addressing her supporters
Nixon said while the result tonight was
not what we hope for I'm not discouraged
I'm inspired and I hope you are too
she ended her speech by saying by
thanking voters for believing and
fighting and leaving everything in the
field we started something in New York
and it doesn't end today this is just
the beginning and I know that together
we will win this fight well you know
what it's great for her for running and
like yes this was her first timing she's
running for a big office raise her first
big city into the political arena so
like she's got like I feel like there's
always next year for her or the next or
next gubernatorial or she could spend
the time between now and the next
governor race like really building up
her her resume in the political sphere
yeah and it's hard going against someone
who's already had the position and
probably already has the funding it
already has a lot of yeah he's like I
think I was gonna ask you if you thought
that the cinnamon raisin bagel with lox
really affected her was she eating that
yes you so she ordered like she had a
cinnamon raisin bagel and she was like
I'll have LOX you know onions tomatoes
capers which to be fair I like a sweet
salty combo so I knew what she was kind
of trying to do even though when you
have locks on your bagel it really
should be an everything bagel or sesame
or at least just poppy seed but fine as
a Jew I have very strong opinions about
this but that was like the major story
that came out three days ago they were
like a gasp I can't detach though they
they make people went absolutely
outraged that no that's outrageous
because like both things are so good and
j-just like shouldn't be eaten together
yeah they're like oh my god
chicken wings of ice cream I don't think
mom and and you know what if someone
who's trying to like be that represent
like the representation for New York
like you do not represent New York if
you're getting a cinnamon like mmm New
Yorkers are so bagel crazy and like
bagels and Ikes hello right and it's
like honestly like she's like with that
order she says like I'm
in New York I'm not a Jew is what she
said which basically is like I'm not a
New Yorker and she's not a juice like I
don't expect her to be but like a New
York like even if she just got like a
toasted everything bagel with like some
chive cream cheese totally that no one
would judge you I just wonder like how
many people were like I can't vote for
this woman's clearly unhinged I can't
vote for her now because she had a
cinnamon raisin bagel with lox like that
was the number one story I saw about her
and it was like oh dear God we're gonna
win it's hard
she's an actress like I feel like we all
really got behind her it was a very
interesting race to watch simply because
a she was in Sex in the City which is
literally arguably like the most New
York by email centric show right right
right but like and so she's definitely
like a rep like a New Yorker she's a New
Yorker I think we I saw her campaigning
on the streets like three months ago
all the time everywhere but like that
does not a governor make correct I think
you have to I mean an funding you need
funding right like you just have to have
the money to do it and you need
experience so like maybe this year
wasn't her year but like if she's like
passionate about this and she has good
ideas and like then you know what
patience is a virtue it is and stick
with it and a lot of times it takes a
bunch of rejections before you get that
one and then it'll be worth it and you
know more and you know how to campaign
so I mean listen she probably did really
well for her first time yeah her first
time it's not like she got three votes
right I wanted to see what the votes
were but I couldn't even see but anyways
I'm here for it like a little celebrity
in the New York healthier ya station
wants to run for mayor against bill de
blasio I think you're all for that you
have my vote okay and you just switch
the office thing that's my vote yes
you're not a fan of de Blasio yeah we
were just talking about this like just
this city is being like you step outside
your apartment and it's just like the
city is being run into the ground I'm so
many different levels I don't even know
where to start and like I always want to
start with the traffic like I literally
thought I was gonna throw up when I got
here this morning like I was so queasy
and it caused a lot of like stop start
stop start and it's just like these
these made-up rules like I can't turn
here why I can turn here like I I know
that I can make a right here and I'm
making me go to a different Street it's
just
adding congestion to that one Street and
I don't like why do we have streets if
you're not allowed to turn yeah you have
to do like a complete square in order to
just to make that left to turn I'm like
just let me turn left like I'm as long
as I'm running over a pedestrian right
let me drive No and so that's just one
element and the city it's just it's not
good I was walking down the street in
like a swanky neighborhood last night
and it smelled so bad like foul really
well the garbage on the street right I
smell way more weed than I do garbage
yeah yeah I feel like weed is everywhere
now it's it's the perfume of New York
City oh how about so interesting I feel
like I just don't hang out and like as
cool of places but I repeat like I say
hang out in like weenie area where it's
just like you go look at a high Swank
I'm with like a low like degenerates of
New York you know we're talking about
the other day and me and you are the
woman to like put in the recommendation
that Bethenny needs to run for mayor
that would be as she certainly would
have the funding for that we have the
funding she would have she has the the
community management skills like she cuz
she has no skills she did Puerto Rico I
think that's like she has a humanitarian
philanthropy aspect abroad nice dad I
just feel like running a city it's like
yes you need like political knowledge
but especially for New York City one you
need to be a New Yorker yep and two you
need to like just know how to like run
[ __ ] like I can't explain it like
running a big company it's similar like
cuz the city is a big business and she's
a strong woman the only thing I would
think I would worry about that politics
aside is brim you know she doesn't
really come out a lot about Bryn and
when you're in politics unlike anything
else now it's all a yeah one infra they
dive into every single thing so I worry
about this manner to it I mean not if
she's were I mean I wonder I wouldn't
say never say never who knows I've never
heard her necessarily interested in
politics who knows though you know that
like people want change but I just worry
about bran being in the spotlight
especially if she grows older and right
nothing he's not running for office of
any sort like it's gonna be bad yeah and
it would all be out there and all the
Jason stuff and everything and it would
be messy and and it should be definitely
be sacrificing herself on on the on the
arc of of New Yorkers yeah um what about
Caroline's you will running would you
have what you have
I wouldn't you literally just ski
that same dirty look as done like two
times ago when I was on when you're like
team caroling I think it was daggers
right here to me Jackie like that's how
it was and I you know the nicest person
I know so now I feel like I just like
hate me great I love you and I know your
team Bethany now and that's all that
matters you know right you changed your
mind now right it felt like Carol I mean
it saying she's a reporter she's smart
you know she had her hand in political
things I'm just tossing it out there as
an idea I never even heard her talk
about it but you are not for it okay I'm
not here for I'm not here for it like I
would rather have some young ran for
mayor what she did to that town how she
could do for this city we could be 2013
a a month 32k I love the politics that
are happening in you're right yeah I'm
not a see Jackie O's political world
like SimCity but you're it's only fun
with New York for me because I feel like
I really understand the city and like
I'm definitely very green and like very
um young and I want to learn but like
let's see where I'm at in 20 years
running a mayor let's see oh let's see
the morning toast and you know year 20
let's see well right yep I'm here for it
I'll go I'm taking notes Nats yeah I
feel like I've been mayor I don't know
it's a lot but I got my plate and I get
really stressed out but um we'll see
well show you maybe the city will need
me by then but never say nothing I think
Bethany would be great I think Andy
would be great I mean what he's done for
the West Village oh my god Josh Street I
know he's always like I'm basically the
mayor and he's the mayor of Jane Street
for sure 100% and he's made videos and I
had so many articles came back the next
day like his Andy Cohen running for
office and I was like if Andy runs for
office this will be the best thing ever
and it's not that far-fetched like
really it isn't I mean he gets in but I
don't think he wants to be in the
political world because it is so much
dirty that it's so much nastier than
anything that could ever happen on
television right it is a nasty place no
matter what side you lie on but I do
like him kind of being this like Street
local authority on trash and cleaning up
buildings I always want him to be like
can you come to my area where I live cuz
I've got some grievance grievances like
construction happening all the time he
gets he gets [ __ ] done he can Jess
honestly here for it um I'm really just
here for anything just change we gotta
shake it up yeah Chicago yeah starring
bella thorne and zendaya
okay this next story is like really
crazy yeah Fitness bike maker peloton
accuses rival flywheel of stealing its
technology peloton interactive
incorporated the maker of popular at
home fitness bikes is suing flywheel
sports for allegedly stealing the
technology that pipes cycling classes
into your users home the latest sign in
the intensifying competition for
boutique fitness systems peloton claims
in a lawsuit filed Wednesday in the US
District Court Marshal in Texas that
flywheel known for its brick-and-mortar
studio classes created a copycat of
peloton's bike using the company's
proprietary patents the fly anywhere
bike peloton claims uses the same
technology to display live and archived
cycling classes track rider performance
and compare at home riders performance
to others like I know this is about
flywheel in peloton they're like reading
this I can't help but think about
Instagram and snapchat like how can
peloton swing flywheel but snapchat
can't sue Instagram for stealing their
entire idea well this is where it kind
of becomes not to get all Shark Tank II
but this is where it becomes really
difficult because in that article you
said that there's proprietary technology
that they have a patent for so a peloton
and I don't know the answer that's
because a peloton had patented a certain
way to view classes and a certain way to
view your instructure instructor like
they can sue anybody and that could just
be like forward-facing screen and right
slide comes on to show you what Jackie
is biking at it when I'm biking at then
they can if there is a patent for that
it seems kind of weird to have a there's
so many different patents and if you
like shark team like you come here they
have a plan for anything and then that's
really just how you make your money it's
not even your product is good it's just
totally lit and they just pay you in
lawsuits and now you're a company and
that's and that's unfortunate right
because I also feel like it stifles
innovation when you have so many patents
it's like you can't like a certain
high-heeled you know what I mean like
you're stifling innovation however it's
a good point of like why Instagram like
there's there's so many online classes
like if you look up YouTube you could
probably just type in like peloton class
right and get it right there right so
that with technology like that in
internet classes I don't really know
like how original proprietary it is yeah
I just feel like this separation should
be a and the instructor you know what I
mean like if you love a certain
SoulCycle struck instructor you're gonna
go to her not go into like a peloton
class and maybe the types of workouts
that you do should vary it but it's
really
hard to say like you know how many at
home workout things are there like I
workout at home all the time I've used
like hundreds and hundreds and hundreds
right I'm in DVDs this goes back to the
80s a robo sighs Kim Kardashian like
right bootie Kenya Moore Phaedra Parks
with Lil donkey booty right yeah exactly
like it's really hard to tell is all
this time it really is a Taylor's oldest
it's very beating the Beast so I'm
curious to see what they patented and
how they could get away with it and what
the ruling is because I feel like this
will be like this will set a precedent
you know right because one way or the
other right because what if it's like a
boxing like peloton but in boxing so if
you have to buy like a bag and then
there's like technology and that where
you can look at the you know it says
like you're punching speed what is the
difference between peloton and mat like
is it just the different type of workout
I don't know and also technically
flywheel was the one who started
competitive cycling like where yeah
that's the first thing I heard about it
right Fido
so peloton did this at home instructor
cycling where you also are competitive
and you get to feel like you're in a
class right but flywheel started the
competitive leaderboards class total
which seems so [ __ ] stressful I've
never been to of do they also do that in
SoulCycle don't know so they don't use
every man for himself I don't know how I
don't even know like what my resistance
is against someone else is like I'm
focused on myself and they don't have a
leaderboard or nothing okay okay so yeah
that stresses me so like it goes both
ways that stresses me out they seem I
mean I'm curious to see what the ruling
will be yeah me too I wonder how what
they could have possibly patented I'm
curious about that and like just the
Shannon beador of it all on her peloton
bike that David got for her and then
took back which is I'm like you
literally called her fat every single
day right you know you want her to work
out then you take it back but also not
everyone can afford a peloton bike like
there are a couple thousands of dollars
so it's weird that they would be
assuming each like oh you don't want
seems like they should go into a
partnership like you want
brick-and-mortar you want to go classes
go to flywheel but if you want to
workout at home and you want to do that
they should incorporate themselves right
each other right lesson Les Moonves to
me
yeah there's less money
much less move a shrink or die yeah I'm
ready I'm here for it we'll keep you
posted on the legal updates I'm not sure
yes and this next story is exciting
interesting just love a little branding
merger news okay Hershey's buys Pirate's
Booty to double down on healthy snacks
Hershey's is increasing its bet on
healthy food the chocolate maker
announced on Wednesday that has agreed
to acquire pirate brands which makes
pirate booty smart puffs and original
Tings in order to expand its healthier
snacks portfolio the ng foods will sell
the suite of snacks for four hundred and
twenty million dollars Wow good for them
I remember when I was eating tired
foodie like out in these streets cuz I
he always had to eat healthy snacks
growing up and then I saw like in Star
Magazine like there was like a product
placement like I don't go in his pouch
or one of those parents meeting with her
kids and I was like and I couldn't you
were like I am so Paltrow right now
Pirate's Booty though doesn't taste
healthy that's why I like it I love
pirates but it's so delicious you're
like I don't I'm glad that it's healthy
because smart food popcorn although is
like so good I probably know it's like
terrible for you so I love pirates booty
and what it did I could eat like five
bags of those in one sitting
me too like even when I'm being healthy
that's like my my cheap snack but I
don't even feel that bad yeah you know
what I've also been eating a lot of
recently skinny girl popcorn very good
like it the portion size bags the the
portions that the bags come in are very
good they're not like too small they're
not too big yep and I feel like I had
like a normal serving of a couple have
you ever had quest protein chips yeah
they make a lot of protein bars for like
working out quest I've seen the brain
yes will they make these protein chips I
don't even know where you can get them
online one of my friends gave them to me
and they're like very light they're not
even made out of chips and the entire
bag is like 40% protein for your day
it's insane and it's not like you're
eating like fried potatoes it's like
baked and the way that it pops up and
it's delicious and light and I think you
probably like it I don't know if there's
like some anti Atkins thing in there but
you should at least check it out
I would love to 1% of your protein
that's why you say I need more protein
like I'm cramping up left and right and
I bruising so easily oh I got crazy
bruises from camco they were so weird we
were like at porcelains kids they were
the most intense looking bruises I've
ever had but they don't hurt to the
touch isn't that weird yeah that is
weird it's just like
I don't need more ironing those toasters
really like killed you yeah I see was
technically Claudia that almost killed
Adam she gets competitive yeah yep she
gets a competitive golf cart drive yeah
um anyways I think this is really
exciting good for Pirate's Booty I mean
yeah they've been out here in these
streets like trying to make people
healthier for years now and I'm glad
that it is paying off for them and now
they just got 420 million let's go out
and celebrate yeah let's do it where we
going specific yeah it feels very well
let's go to McDonald's and just like
anti-v healthy right that seems fun but
it also is like there's probably three
companies that on every single snack
right Hershey's Campbell's right I'm
like I don't even know my eyes or
frito-lay yeah I'm like I don't even
know who runs that but it's nice if
people are doing more of a healthy
initiative at a good price because
that's the problem it's usually so
expensive right yeah Pirate's Booty is
good
Park City's good pop shits are good
baked Lay's are good I forgot about
Tings when you just said it I was like
are those a triangle I don't know I
don't know I don't eat those oh yes yeah
or on Peapod com waiting for my grocery
delivery you're a bad girl yes it
changed my life mostly when I go grocery
shopping anymore
I want drinks yeah like I like to have a
fridge full of drinks it helps me like
stay healthy um but I can't carry
anything like from the grocery store
even when I'm not buying drinks like
carrying all the groceries don't do it
so this is delivery and it's like really
well price it's owned by Stop & Shop so
yeah you're getting good prices for your
groceries they deliver to your door and
it really has helped me like or else I
just wouldn't have groceries what's your
number one drink like when you open your
fridge what's like the thing that you're
going to probably seltzer because it
will hydrate me and also be tasty but
then also I'm love a good glass of cold
iced tea oh diet ice like diet Arizona
here for it yeah here for it a little
half and half a little half lemonade
half iced tea Arnold Palmer and in for
it what is your favorite brand of
seltzer I'm very particular about my
sell Joker drink it's also for like 25
years
right now I go like there's some that I
like I know so I never even finish a
bottle of seltzer they need to me
seltzer bottles that are smaller cuz
once you like it once it's open for an
hour it's like flat I mean the liter
bottles yeah or even just like water
bottle like they just need to make like
miniature saucers because I never need
that much seltzer because I just need
that initial crunch yeah but right now I
really enjoy Poland Spring Lemon
but then I also like like clear splash
the flavors okay all right um that
Lacroix girl not a look low not away
whatever I like Pellegrino
I like Perrier those are the same and
they're fancy I'm a vintage girl I was
about to say vintage those keep the most
fit is I think they're so [ __ ] fizzy
they are so fizz I mean there's like
five milligrams of sodium you have to
like check even though it's 0% you
always have to check but they are the
cans of vintage you will never get a
better thirst quencher than I can't
event assault sir I totally agree yeah
more than I don't know if they sell them
monthly that I'll have to check uh
anyways now it is time to pick your
brain okay let's do it to get the real
scoop and the tea on what is going on in
the Bravo community and the NBC
community I feel like we related almost
every single of your stories to back to
Bravo right and so now like I'm done
holding myself back from time yes not
like right exactly like uncho know
yourself and just let it rip oh yeah
here we go first up in New York reunion
the most recent we haven't you haven't
been on since the reunion taped unless
it was gonna be explosive you did not
lie and I just want to say I want to
thank you and the whole Bravo team for
putting a lot of the meat in the first
reunion yeah because I know sometimes
you drag it out to the third because you
want people to watch but it's like I'll
be watching the third reunion even if
they're just talking about like even if
they're just sitting around braiding
their hair I would never not watch a
part of a rewrite of a show that I've
literally invested six months of my life
in and it's like yes the big
conversations are important but
sometimes are interesting nuggets like
Bethenny's facial expression when she's
watching the package of Tinsley and
Scott I thought was so cute and sweet
and there's no beef between them and
like that was important for me it was
genuine it was genuine yes so happy for
her and wants the best for her I feel
like my favorite moment I think this was
in part three you might know more when
when Bethenny and jorindel like
apologized to each other after are you
drunk or a drunk you know when there was
that whole gang her one regret him Ecija
one we're gonna the season and Dorinda
you could tell was just like so touched
by her apology and that's all it takes
like that's the thing it was Lessman she
was very she was very less booth
Bethenny and Carole though what that's
way out of that friendship what was
Andy's reaction his reaction to Carole
telling him he's full of [ __ ] and that
he's scared of me um I don't you know I
didn't talk to him after because I like
to not I like doctor bombard him too
much but listen I don't think Andy has a
really good head about his
his shoulders he takes everything in
stride but I don't think anyone wants to
be said that they're full of [ __ ]
especially when he's not full of [ __ ]
right he's just trying to explain you
know he's always I think tried to toe
the line and be devil's advocate and be
like okay well but this time line on
Bethenny's phone says rest like I'm not
trying to say that you're wrong I'm just
being like what says eleven I think
you're bringing in screenshots from
someone else's phone like I want this is
from the horse's mouth right exactly so
when he got called back who's our
primary source
yeah there's our a secondary source and
for a journalist writer girl you should
know the difference Wow your company you
should have been at that thing I'm a
history major you don't [ __ ] with my
sources you're all about the receipts
Jackie you're all about the receipts and
I'm all about primary sources of course
you have to have it I mean this is why
journalism is like the way that it is
today because people be like oh yeah I
read this on like da-da-da-da-da
I'm like yeah that's not look like three
bullet points but I need the rest
I need all of the bullet points because
right it's called contact sweetie you
need to look it up I love how heated you
are even like weeks later and I think
with Andy like yeah he's a journalist in
that way you know what I mean I mean he
certainly knows how to report on a story
he worked in news forever so he gets the
idea of history and contacts but I don't
think anyone likes to be told they're
full of [ __ ] what's funny is that I feel
like the audience in the Twitterverse
and the fans were more pissed off than
him they were like you don't see that to
Andy like he was in the Mafia you're
like you insulted this like you know he
did and she is paying the price
for sure and it's like Andy I'm sure
it's just cool calm and collected it's
just like fire no no no no no no but
like she could be if that's what he had
wanted like he has the pad like he's her
boss like if my is injury snitch right
told me I was full of [ __ ]
snitches get yourself one thing from
martinis murder right if she said that
if she said I was [ __ ] I'd be like
it's like that's not nice cuz you're my
sister but then I would also be like
watch what you're saying like this could
be your last day yeah and I think for
any were just like hey even if you think
that I am don't use that you know it's
never it's never a good look for anybody
to say that even if even if it was right
it just doesn't make her look like an
adult or presentable you know and I
think that was really his point
yeah I totally agree um but the road was
worth it for you the rhenium was
definitely worth it for me a lot of like
loose ends were tied up it was just
unfortunate that you know the news came
out about Denis is passing like the week
before
part 1 of the reunions so so much has
changed since the reunion even though
and that had that happened like three
weeks after we even stopped filming
right yeah it wasn't even like that much
time has passed because I really felt
like we were up to speed is just like I
mean bad timing obviously and just a
horrible thing to have happened for
Bethenny on the reunion because like she
was already going through so much and
it's like just knowing where she would
be at now it's just like I felt for her
oh my god and I haven't I haven't seen
anything or her come out about anything
I haven't been keeping as much in touch
with it as I have because I felt like
the dentist thing kind of fell by the
wayside there was just so much that was
happening unfortunately but that's
devastating that's horrible no one wants
that to happen
totally but I'm also kind of like glad
that all of this like has kind of made
the dentist thing like less of a topic
of discussion because like he really was
a private person and his family seems to
be very private and so and Bethenny was
private about him right exactly know
that it's like we're just all so like
hella hungry for it of course
yeah but so I'm it's almost like
everything works like happens way that
it should I know time is everything and
but the ring and happening at like then
it's just like fresh news to talk about
all just LuAnn stuff LuAnn on watch what
happens live yes I have to be honest so
I watched part three and then I
immediately watch watch what happens I'd
and like I just thought it was it I just
felt like she wasn't taking it seriously
I can't explain it like I didn't feel
like we got like a reunion version of
her I feel like we got like a Giovanni
cabaret like she never went to rehab the
second time version of her and it's like
Tristan I needed a little bit more
seriousness about what happened right
and like you needed like a heartfelt
moment I've heard of being like yes yes
the cabaret show was amazing but this is
also what I'm going through and it's
very serious right it's like the way
that she was after she went to rehab the
first time like I would have appreciated
that after the second time and also more
of a like a reunion tone to it cuz it
was very like watch it happens I'd like
fun funny yeah but I was like I wanted I
just I don't know I can't explain it you
want to lust your body and I also
thought it was gonna be a one-on-one
which is always more serious in nature
oh my god I remember when we like I
remember the Teresa Joe like one-on-one
with Andi like they're always so they're
like journalistic rapport
everything better just like I love how
Andy does those right I love it I'm so I
thought that that was the vibe so I was
just like I'm Jerry O'Connell jovani
dresses this is fun but I didn't get
what I felt like I needed you know and
and I felt like LuAnn would like when
she was responding to stuff she would
like just have like a one-liner yeah
instead of being like well to like
she'll be like I wasn't at the Beekman
in this summer but it's like maybe it
happened on June 20th and technically it
wasn't this summer yeah exactly right so
I just I didn't like I didn't feel like
and the other women weren't there to be
like Kathy where she was like a few
skating the details it seemed like to
you what the other women weren't there
to call around so she could kind of just
get away with what she was saying
right yeah it's also God on the flip
side of that it also be really hard I
mean granted yes it's what you signed up
for but having your whole life and going
through this really really traumatic
thing with you know eight other ladies
just kind of coming at you for it and
you have to talk to Andy about it and
it's a live show it's probably a lot of
pressure for her so she might not have
known what to say right you know and she
didn't want anything taken out of
context because she's really in the
limelight she has children
yeah I could see it being very very
difficult I could see that too and also
overall I'm loving her this would her
season the friendship that she has with
Bethenny and Sonja as well it's just
everything I didn't know that I needed
totally and there was a video that one
of the morning toasters posted in the
group the other day of Bethenny Ramona
and now the new housewife oh sorry
LuAnn Ramona and the new housewife
Barbara all at Macy's supporting
Bethenny Skinnygirl jeans line right and
I'm just fun to see so fun to see yeah
and I love LuAnn and Bethenny just like
supporting each other and the way I'm
saying that Bethenny and Dennis like
helped her with a lot of her legal
issues in Palm Beach just I'm here for
it I'm here for to like their sisterhood
in that the other women like they came
into the reunion thinking that like they
were the [ __ ] the dream team as Carol
said was like only Yolanda Foster can
say and they lost yeah they won the
battle but they lost the war they were
basically you in the color Wars and then
everyone else was Claudia cuz she had
two guys on her team right if we're
bringing it back to camp tails you're no
Carol no no no Sonja I would say I'm
that I'm the Sonia really that's
Jennifer I'm the plastic straw that
stirs the drink yes you of course you
are I think I did
look on the reunion who did you think
was best dress oh my god that's really
the vote the watch happens i voters said
Bethenny but he's telling him was number
two yeah Bethenny had that like ponytail
thing which was a little interesting um
I mean I thought Sonja looked really
pretty and she was also wearing her own
dress which I really liked and I like to
rindas hair
I actually thought Ramona looked pretty
classy though just as like in terms of
just a look yeah I liked it it wasn't
egregious it wasn't sometimes with tansy
like you never know what you're gonna
get which is always really fun
my problem with Cindy is like I love her
style sometimes but she also just buys
everything off the rack that
self-portrait and Alison Olivia whether
it's good or bad and this and this is
now we're over to Amber Union dresses
I think that dress no was she on the box
with it was a glue self-portrait
toddlers and tiaras yes it was very it
was very prissy it was very yeah Queen
and royal royal royalty that's nice of
you to say well it was it was a lot I
mean look at my style like I should not
be talking I would wear a suit because I
would just want to get it over I mean
honestly you would look at me that yeah
I would love that
like just like black Kourtney Kardashian
at the Great Gatsby themed Kris Jenner
birthday party done that's me that's
what I would go at um how does Andy feel
about Carol selling her used underwear
on Poshmark
did you see this I did not see the hash
mark is like a resale yeah I used much
more me too yeah and Carol was actually
been on it for a while and she sells a
lot of her clothes and I'd like when I
used to do it a lot more than I do now
it's just a lot of work I know do we see
herself like she obviously liked his has
great fashion that's all she cares about
if you asked Bethenny yes
so she was selling some of her clothes
but now I'm surprised you don't buy it
and then just burn it just for spite
Jackie yeah her underwear would burn but
no clothes those are precious
yeah there's what you're saving from the
fire blood if your apartment well
actually none of my clothes I think but
my handbags and shoes like they're just
and they're all like out like one would
be like a birthday present just all
emblematic more like a time in my life
totally but anyways now she's selling
her lingerie on Poshmark and I'm glad
this hasn't reached Andy I don't know if
I would buy lingerie on Poshmark
I would definitely not lingerie is one
of those things where it's like you want
it just to me like I just like I want it
fresh I wonder if I hurt you you never
wore it it was
sitting in the draw with your other
lingerie that was hopefully worn yeah
there's like there's pheromones that
could have passed through I just there's
- I'm just too OCD to buy anybody let
alone
Carol's but anybody's underwear right
other retail site like do I want the tag
fresh package you know Victoria's Secret
like they do a really nice job it's not
so expensive like I have like 5 for 20
I'd rather have a new victoria's secret
than used with Perla well words to live
by
joy to live by um we spoke a little bit
yesterday with Scotty about the new
housewife yeah Barbara
Claudia has met her she went to the
countess and friends with her yeah and
really likes her really enjoys good so
we are excited about it I personally
didn't feel like we needed a new
housewife okay um but I I'm here for it
and like I hope she has a lot some
really big shoes to fill and a lot to
like live up to it's hard to get into
that group as we're now seeing on OC
which we'll get to in a second New York
is tough New York is a tough and anyway
it's just a tough city like the OCE I
mean we'll get to it but like those we
they always say that like Shannon hates
a new girl they're always like up Qin's
always gonna hate the new girl like
doesn't matter her news like Shannon's
gonna hate her that's hilarious because
like Shannon was the new girl not very
long
right which is funny he's like a wacky
woman I love her like [ __ ] not like
there's some most affable all the time
so like she should be giving other
people a chance she is doing to them
what Heather do birthday to her yeah I
think it's a little bit of like this
this I don't want to say hazing cuz it's
obviously not violent or anything like
that there's no not doing anything
illegal but it is a little bit of like
this initiation process being like you
have to come to us right we are not
going to you which I also understand
because like a lot of some of these
women have been there from the beginning
but a lot of them like have spent years
like really making this show what it is
like giving their whole lives for this
show and it's like you get to come in on
our peak right now right good for you
but you gotta earn your stripes amen
and I get that so that's why I'm I'm I
look forward to seeing how Barbara how
she does and how she's able to integrate
in the group and I hope she really is
friends with some of the people going
into it but I always helps as opposed to
bringing in like a rogue woman you need
to have and being like our kids go to
piano class together right it has there
has to be some natural integration you
have to have been friends before or
childhood friends or friends and friends
there has to be something natural
just like drop anybody in right and
that's actually huge for uh a close-knit
group who've been through so much
together yes like on a newer show like
Dallas
I even Potomac like you could it's
easier to do when we're in like Season
nine ten eleven there's history there's
so much history to go in and that is why
I'm here for the bringing back of all
about housewives but not Lydia
McLaughlin you are yeah and you really
you really don't like I really didn't
like her this season and it's like I
should because she's so cute and like
peppy and spunky and her mom but like I
just saw like yes she thinks he's she's
the friendship whisperer but she was
like really excluding Shannon yeah and I
didn't think that was cool especially
that last year was the hardest year of
Shannon's life have you
it's horrible I'm actually so proud of
Shannon to see how she is now especially
with her new Food Lion totally and I was
just literally before I came in here I
was like scrolling through my Facebook
or Instagram and I saw these like
sponsored posts by her for talking about
this really you know sensitive issue she
was you know forty pounds overweight or
however much it was and she really
fought to get it back it's truly
inspiring and she is so down to earth
I love the OC girls I just love them I
love a little oh I like some of them but
like this like and I'm not caught up on
this season and it's like next week's
episode is like really good because
someone Kelly starts [ __ ] with which
I've been waiting for do you like Gina
then with the accent okay well first of
all Emily looks like a Gina and Gina
looks like an Emily yes I never use them
I know
and also Emily looks like chessy so it's
just there's so many names floating
around like Jesse it is but Gina doesn't
look like a Gina she looks like Emily
looks like Gina is really confusing
I looked up her husband the other day or
I think they maybe they're getting a
divorce I looked up he's super cute
really super kid she's really cute she
has some like really pretty she's some
weird looks like in her testimonials but
I appreciate that the taking of a chance
and I would never shown anyone for like
yeah going hard on a glam and like
sticking to a look totally um I just
liked her attitude I like her attitude
too but like it is really just Harper
and when she had that conversation with
Vicki and they realize that like she's
the same age as Vicki's daughter I was
just like like okay this is a different
generation yeah yeah it's just a
different night but I like Tina and
Tamra's friendship and I like yeah
I like her I think it's just really hard
to go in that's the firt like that is
the oldest show I think it's really hard
to be a new person on that show and you
so you have to be bold and make a
statement but then also it's like but
you have to do it in a way where it's
like you don't ruffle too many feathers
it's hard it's a it's a delicate it's a
it's a fine line it is a fine line and
it's really cool to see like this New
Yorker broad come in with like these you
know classy like you know California
ladies I like it's like a fish out of
water I like seeing that that's one of
the reasons they were really really like
Jeana because you do have to be strong
and she's got that like tough vibe about
her you know and wears hats and smoked
cigars I'm really looking forward to
this season however yes
I got a point-counterpoint I like a New
Yorker she is just like she seems like
the SNL version of an housewife like a
caricature right I like people who are
from New York I mean I imagine if I ever
left New York yeah I would be like The
New Yorker but I wouldn't be like so
stereotypical outward yeah like just the
way I react to things is very New York
like moving on you know I know you're
too attitude is New York not like your
physical your boy like just crash for
sure right yeah but she's always just
talking about being a New Yorker and
it's like it's also like how Cameron's
always talking about being blond red
smart right weight right although we're
waiting to see I do get the sense and I
don't know this for sure but I'm sure
it's really hard Gina had to move across
country she thought she was gonna be
with her husband she never sees her
husband like she probably really misses
New York no and she like puts up with it
like she deals with a lot those kids oh
my gosh she's three of them she's alone
and now they're getting divorce which is
like sad but I'm glad I'm glad she has a
show like yes she has a good support
system emily has three kids as well yeah
and that least they're not she's not the
only new person right yeah like you
could even have that two of their own no
I just think like you know three kids
she's a New Yorker she's completely out
it was like you needed to have someone
there to also be in her corner and there
it's kind of nice to see like two
newbies together yeah yeah there's a new
united front there and I also think that
the way Gina reacted to the husband
Emily's husband thing she was like I
thought she played it so cool cuz she
was like I was trying to like minimize
that's not a good look for you right but
then then like so Emily's coming out her
being like at least my husband's there
and she's like [ __ ] don't start with me
like that like I literally was not gonna
make a big deal about it you were the
one who went to every girl right I feel
like when Emily told everyone she
thought everyone might think was funny
cuz she was like my husband kick G now
cuz she thought being annoying oh she's
mad I relate you know I relate and
there's kids in the house like I
actually do really it sometimes you
don't understand how loud you're being
and also when she said that when she
said that like my husband kick Jeanne
out I didn't think anything was like
weird at all until all of the women were
like I can't believe you let your
husband talk to her that way and I was
like I'm sure he because he's not on
camera that much yeah if you have young
kids in the house I've never had a child
but I can only imagine that they're
actually sleeping and they've quieted
down that's all you want right you don't
want anyone disturbing this piece of 15
minutes that you can have as a parent
I'm sure that's what happened and I'm
sure that's what he was trying to get
across
did you know like the party was over he
wasn't like no parties it was like it's
like hated happening around being loud
go home right drinking smoking cigars
like it's just not a good parental
situation to understand but I also am
not caught up so like maybe we've seen
more of Shane which is Emily's husband
Needham um but I don't know I didn't
like feel one particular way or the
other about it right it felt like just
like she was me so annoying even while
all the women were there right yeah
women were annoyed by her they left her
at the table so it's like oh no you're
allowed to be annoyed and like leave her
out but chain can't tell her to get out
yeah I think it was just like a man and
a husband who's not part of the you know
core group telling this woman you know
it was very easy to take out of context
I think it was very much like a gender
thing yes yes not being kicked out right
got it
um next up I want to talk about Dallas
okay I'm all caught up and I just I love
this franchise and I and I'm sweet as
brandy oh my god I can't we just like I
love she's so nice she is so nice
they're all really nice but Brandi it's
just a little ginger he's so cute your
family is so cute and like what she did
like I'm so happy for her she did it in
a week like could you imagine you're
like Maya your whole life and then BOOM
you have a baby just in your and who's
adorable adorable and it's just like so
meant to be it like feels like hers and
yeah just is taking
the role and it's so sweet to see it's
so nice and I love that Stephanie was
the one who brought Bruin into her life
because they like even no matter what
happens with the show like they will
forever be connected by that yeah and I
don't I think that they do have a really
really strong bond to anyway like there
have always been you know it's a little
bit of Ramona Sonja where you're just
kind of like yeah no matter what you go
through we love each other right end of
the day right that feels it's makes
sense that Stephanie is one who did that
yeah I'm really just happy for I think
that just as good for there what do you
think about LeAnn lock-ins like
transformation and trying to get more
meditative and a little bit calmer angry
I love Leeanne Locken she came on the
show wanting to meet just fell in love
she's a great name she's coming on next
week I love that we cited I am here for
her like calming transformation but like
I feel like she's either at two extremes
like she's either you know being loud
drinking up all night Marie with a knife
or she's going to bed early with her
bowl and not really being herself
and lay up and then so she feels like oh
I was really good I can now go back to
this right but there needs to be at this
where she's like still having fun
drinking like being out with everyone
but just doesn't get to that level you
know so I don't think she needs to
change who she is entirely cuz I think
she's like a great girl like I think
she's so fun and I think she's like it's
funny and a good friend and like has a
lot to offer
absolutely so I feel like she thinks she
needs to take all of the way like she
needs to shrink her and make delet to
this but she needs to just make it like
I don't like this I love that we're
talking about you know when Kara was
like I have a really large campus I was
like I don't think anyone really knows
what that means right so apparently like
she said it wrong anyway yeah yeah there
I mean yes there's all different I'm
sure she probably does have a very large
hippocampus I don't really know what
that I was a neuroscience major I don't
really know what where are you yeah I
was oh my goodness is that actually like
we must come in handy with like this
shows cuz like all this is sociological
like I just love psychology of human
relationships in general which is why I
work honestly it's probably who I work
at Bravo cuz I look at that through a
different lens like well I'm looking
from like a scientific lens that is so
interesting that's right I like trying
him take a step back and have this like
intellectual like argument about the
house was like oh she's just a [ __ ] or
like she thought I'm like no no no no I
was like let's take a look at like the
the context the history of everything
and maybe you know what she's going
through in her life I just love the
psychology of that stuff I read about it
all the time it's like mail a copy fun
fact about here where'd you go to
college I went to Lafayette it's in
Easton Pennsylvania
oh not far from the Poconos not far at
all not far at all
also I feel like it's like similar vibes
to Colgate it's in this exact same
family were in the same Patriot League
so Lafayette Colgate bobtail they're all
the same I see you on the turf yeah love
it actually collate it sounds really
nice I read the Athletics seemed like
they gave up all of their hotel they
come on yeah hotel but I don't know if
their hotel rooms or their budget for
food and travel for the football team
and they're giving it to like all of the
people who need to evacuate from 13
variants which is like there's such a
small school like the football team like
I don't even know that they have that
big of a budget but it's just like a
nice thing to do that's a super-sweet
thing yeah especially from like a small
liberal arts college right now like no
one knows about right that's tiny like
Lafayette had 2,300 students right no my
high school was bigger right yeah
2700 students and it's like you know
they're just doing it from the goodness
of their heart cuz like they're not a
school that gets a lot of press and I
think they're probably just like oh and
we got pressed yeah
totally it's really nice it's sweet
shout out to Colgate I'm visiting in
November oh and my five year reunion is
in I went to mine I went so it's very
weird because you're you're far enough
out where you have your own career and
people know what you do but you're also
like that's also kind of a middle stage
where like not everyone is like
well-established yet yeah everyone's
still kind of want equal playing field
still like I still starting out in your
career it's not like Romy and Michele
where it's like you have to make up a
career right and like everyone's married
with children like everyone's and I
still babies look like monkey right like
everyone's still pretty young and not
that many people are married or have
children yet right ten years is really
right that's what I've heard like I feel
like five years gonna be really fun and
like literally I cannot it was fun I
have two years until my ten and it's
gonna be interesting that's exciting
yeah I'm excited to hear how it goes
yeah let me know how your five year goes
um okay Dallas I feel like we've covered
you have a lot of ground yes and it's
just it's a great show that the I'm
relationships are great because at one
point it's like everyone's getting along
where's the drama and then don't worry
the drama always comes they found their
stride
yeah the Dallas girls know what's up
they found their stride but is there a
new housewife this season I thought I
met a new housewife or maybe it's just a
friend of the women when we were at the
a magazine summer kickoff party dad I
don't know I don't think so okay look
they don't need it right now yeah I feel
like we're good
weird it were a really good spot um
question yes answer does Andy know about
the toast I am sure Andy knows about no
didn't know that Andy sorry that was
that was he knows about it he knows
about the toast to what degree does Andy
know about the toast
I don't think Andy knows every time I go
on the trophy's but I think he knows
what who you guys are
yes uh-huh it was funny actually cuz I
always like joke I'm like Andy never
knows like what I'm doing like we were
written up in the New York Times and
Anderson Cooper like told him that cuz I
just I just don't want to he's so busy
or whatever not that he'd up he always
wants to know what I'm doing but I just
feel a little like hey by the way Andy
like I was written up in the New York
Times she's like you got to tell me when
these things are happening like this is
great and he told me the other day he's
like I listen to you
and I was like oh no what did you listen
to cuz I always just assumed make he's
too busy he was like I listen to you on
the comments by celebs podcast so he
pays attention like yeah he knows what's
up he's very very knowledgeable okay on
the grind he knows who you are
he's a Jackie O tattoo as back tattoo
[ __ ] stamp it's just your face and then
your and then your handle and that's how
you get followers everywhere right I was
like wondering why I'm getting so many
files yeah it's because of the Andy
Cohen [ __ ] stamp
right foundation so he's been like
showing off oh yeah I told everyone in
me Capri has seen oh everyone of course
if it was like yeah baby like Chucky oh
alright yeah and he was like Darren I
want you to be a housewife like when
whenever that time like dad it alone is
hilarious right yeah would you would you
be a housewife and which franchise would
you want to be on I would probably want
to be I would hope I'd be wealthy enough
to be on Beverly Hills yeah like that's
a that's like my goals right but I do
feel like I'd be New York yeah I mean
I'm a Jersey girl but I'm Way more of a
New Yorker than anything else like race
born in New Jersey so probably New
Jersey of probably New York I wouldn't
be a housewife only because I don't
think of myself like that that's not
where I would shine I'm Way better sort
of observing things like that as opposed
to being in the mix and it would take a
lot for me to be so vulnerable to give
everything on camera right would be a
lot yeah
and my girlfriend would not she wouldn't
be she probably wouldn't want to be on
camera and you'd have to give up that
part of your life and allow it to be
happen anymore
so exactly and I it doesn't work that it
doesn't work that way you need to really
open up every aspect of your life
between children and parents and
significant others and I don't think my
girlfriend would want that so I would be
hesitant well that's actually a great
segue to our next bravo development
which is la like ant getting engaged yes
so happy I'm so happy for she is someone
who came on and she was not
understanding that she needed to totally
open and now her whole life is so open
like her and her man are so [ __ ] cute
and it's like you people can say what
they want but they I don't like her
Instagram is goals I mean a great
granted everyone's Instagram it was like
I thought but like when she got engaged
and it was just them at this table with
like fireworks over them I was like I'm
not even in Jerome ants and I was just
like I love you so much this is amazing
I love her so much and she's so sweet
she's so nice she's so nice I want them
and she's so cool and funny and yeah
she's all about like women empowerment
like supporting other women I love it
totally and she oh my god I just love
her somebody man I feel like she's been
through so much this year and I feel
like yes yeah I mean I don't know her
well enough but we we have lots of
parents like I just feel like and
knowing that Randall asked her dad for
her hand before he passed away like I'm
just so here for them I feel like they
really truly are in love like you two it
doesn't seem like one of those social
media relationships and the whole cast
was there to support her I saw so many
instagrams were like so happy so happy
so happy and it's nice to see him like
out in public now was I had to like I'm
underground Google search who he was he
wouldn't you know how he stream ly legit
are you gonna go see her movie the row
of course oh yeah we generally just I
would look at a picture of her for two
and a half feet late unless mean are you
kidding she's everything what do you
think about the brown hair I am into
brunettes more than anything else out
present company excluded I love gingers
but yeah I like dark okay her features
I'm excited to see how it looks on the
show because she always looks like
someone cried like I feel like she's not
gonna look bad she's one of these people
who actually looks better on TV than she
does on social media is that weird in
have you ever seen her in person though
yes cuz she's she radiates and I
what are you like you are even without
any makeup she's already a 10 and then
the makeup just makes her like a 12 and
you're just like oh I'm speechless
looking at you like literally I've said
to her before like can you just hug me
and swaddle me because this will be the
best thing that's ever happened to me
she's like sure she's beyond cute she is
hot hides Vanderpump rules wrapped
filming for this next season uh I think
we did wrapped filming it it ends
usually around the summer yeah and when
like I'm sure Tom time opening was like
yeah yeah um he's Randall on the season
that I don't know I haven't seen any
cuts of anything so I don't know I'm
sure I don't
has he ever been on camera without I
don't think so I'm sure they'll talk
about the end maybe this was like his
coming-out story yes till next season to
really meet him yeah maybe but I'll wait
I'm never gonna watch Vanderpump rules
um and once they get married
odds of her becoming a housewife of
Beverly Hills really good question no
idea never say never because that would
be the ultimate crossover I mean what
did that just like you go from like the
the kids show to like the Amero it's the
it's American Bravo dream really exactly
right it's the American Bravo dream that
would be insane crossover I'm would be
here for it I would watch it I mean same
yeah obviously I'm already like sweating
or oh la la
speaking of Beverly Hills yeah so last
time you were here you teeth that Denise
Richards could possibly be a full-time
cast member and now she is mm-hmm
um I'm curious yes
like did did Bravo seek her out did she
seek this opportunity out that I don't
know but I just know that it was like
stars aligning type of thing I mean
certainly if bra I can I can't really
speak for what happened because I'm not
involved in that process but certainly
if Bravo's going after someone you kind
of know if you don't want to do it or
you guys do and she's already friends
with some of them so I'm sure she got
like the inside scoop so we can only
imagine that it was like a meeting of
the minds and everyone was on board for
it I don't I doubt there was much
convincing either way okay
she's already famous so what I need to
convince me I like me and I well-known
in her life is public yeah so I would
imagine you'd only want to do it right
and yeah but you're
own story out there as opposed to just
being Charlie Sheen crazy man's ex-wife
correct correct jack well the way me
just went to the Bahamas yes it looked
amazing I'm so excited for the season of
Beverly Hills I can't explain and
Beverly beach by Doreen was just like
thriving there oh I absolutely love the
name and I love ya like I will say okay
is genius behind eh right clucks like
that she's using her Beverly Hills like
right personality persona and it reminds
me of like camp Beverly Hills like those
old shirts that we used to wear totally
but it's like this made-up fantasy like
who wouldn't want to go to Beverly Beach
no that doesn't sound bad at all no not
at all and the swimsuits are really
really cute yes um and I'm really I just
started falling to read on Instagram and
like I'm team to read now her love her
which is so crazy it's so crazy what the
show can do because after the first
season I was you hated her I could not
stand her right and now you sometimes
give it time you never know some
hopefully one statement that could
change people's opinions or one action
or one this like give a time let it
flower and then once the season is done
you can really assess how you felt I go
through a mixture of emotions I go
through a Mona Ramona coaster all the
time so and I'm in it every month I mean
yeah life is a Ramona coaster Claudia is
watching she just wants to know that
Sheena and brandy brought us from Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills - Vanderpump
rules yes I did so Lola and Rando will
bring us and then it would come full
circle
full circle that's right actually
imagine if they are from girls then
segue to Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills and then they go on a yacht and
they're on below deck and like we really
hit every single franchise right and
then like this service from from Anna
pump girls are serving on the yacht yeah
there should be like a and then the chef
is like Tom Colicchio it's like oh my
god this is just Bravo's dream of just
everything going on it's a brother
judged by Padma Padma can judge me all
day I am I am here for that as well
uh I was just gonna ask you was there
ever talk of doing like a Real
Housewives all-star
show yeah I think you know battle of the
Network reality stars with something
actually Andy had his hand in back when
that was and then and people are always
talking about like if you were stuck in
an island you had five housewives like
who would you take so that's always kind
of been in the ether I don't really know
what that would look like right because
they sort of they look their cities in
their own way and I don't really know
that would be like a game show like
putting
my house together that feels a little
weird and uncomfortable like a jersey in
Beverly Hills or Beverly Hills and
Potomac it just doesn't I agree mr.
Meade also on the occasion together
yes but separate but equal yes separate
people
speaking of housewives doing other shows
I actually just caught Kim Richards on
marriage boot camp oh I didn't see that
yeah I think it like just premiered I
don't I was watching something in a
wedding like right into it I couldn't
even stop it
Rob was everywhere Bravo is everywhere
and a family pre-emergence is back on TV
I know I know well you know good for
hope that she's healthy and happy and
doing her thing
agreed um one more thing I wanted to ask
you about we were talking about
play-by-play the new Bravo show yeah we
have Jerry O'Connell coming on next week
so we're gonna ask he's great he's the
nicest so I'm really excited to see the
format of this show cuz it's like for
real men that watch Bravo but apparently
you can't say that anymore
but I will continue to it went okay
until I got an earful that I that
resonate that a you know yeah changes my
mind of course okay so now it's just
like a real women montriveau
fake women on travel people watch Bravo
much like human beings my father so I
what's the format gonna be is it gonna
be like a sports version like the
breakdown like really we need like in
Surrey places yeah yeah like a terrace
traitor technology like whoa Shannon
comes out of left field and does this
less you know it's definitely a wink to
sports and it's definitely it's
definitely a nod to like an ESPN type v
and certainly going like what they think
it's very opinion based it's guys
talking about Bravo we're gonna have a
couple correspondents it's super funny
the comment is great it's just fun to
see guys comment on Bravo because you
don't really realize how many men really
watch it so my whole family watches it
like every time we get together we got
together for Russia Sean and they were
like so tell me about like below deck
med and I was like you you're 50 you're
like my 50 year old uncle like what are
you doing he's like I know but I really
need to know it's a it's a phenomenon
it's gonna be a great job and Jerry is
he's great he's leading it and he's
great and I love that he really is like
like Claudie and I just like a wealth of
Bravo knowledge yes it's not enough to
just watch the shows like you have to
get all of the references like you need
to be able to drop legal jargon at the
drop of a hat like totally so these men
are very well versed in all things Bravo
like they would be they would combat you
and Claudia for sure yeah it would be
amazing I'd love to see a point
I mean if anyone can set it up it's you
yeah what happened to the summer by
bafreux commercials those ended a few
years ago when they were there when we
when I first started and we all love
them I think you know there's really
hard it's really hard to schedule a lot
of Bravo liberties together we have a
lot of people that we have to do in
their huge budgets and we stop those
campaigns but we all like there are a
favorite of everyone around us there you
so that them yeah and I feel like it
starts a lot of drama like within the
cities because it's like if you got it's
like who gets invited to see it and and
yet the new friends tope yeah exactly
exactly like who's sitting next to Andy
who yeah like who's first-string
housewife who gets to play with him it
get camp you know it's that's what it is
whose team is he on at Camp DOS he's
he's he's the Grand Marshal he is the
Grand Marshal like we're playing in his
name and his he's the ringleader right
he's at the circus and he's the ring
that our red also Lalla and Randall just
got a max that make me ask you they're
gonna be on flipping out right on a home
day course how I heard yes I think so I
don't know I don't know if that's true
but I'm I have to check with my sources
and I'll obviously get back well that
would be just an exciting way to see
them together and like I could
understand him not wanting to on
Vanderpump rules like he's a legit yo
syrup but like being on you know a show
about renovating your home it's like
everyone that doesn't make sense
yeah and they probably have a go
gorgeous home and yeah it's amazing and
I'm happy I mean I'm jealous yeah both
like she's just like a phenom of a woman
you know she is it
Lala called me she's probably watching
she probably is yes or likes her friend
is watching it's gonna like tell her to
call you
yeah that's how it works with hey looks
like everyone is a friend six degrees of
separation over here like a friend of a
friend always has something of course of
course
well thank you so much for joining us
I'm sorry the show went so long are you
kidding I love being here with you
this was so fun thank you for dropping
I'm glad cause a degenerate so I could
cut cuz I know she's watching Claudia
degenerate coming here so I could take
over the helm right and as much as
hurricane Florence is really destroying
a lot yeah it brought us together
it did bring us together today happiness
all around yes thanks for having me
anyways I hope everyone has a great
weekend where can everyone follow you at
carpe darren ciear PDA ry n follow me on
instagram all social listen to my
podcast martinis in Murder on oxygen
sounds good also people want me to ask
about Jeff drama
yeah there's none of Jeff Jenni drama
was flipping out and that's still kind
of unfolding right now cuz I guess they
had a huge falling-out and Jeff was
talking about it in his radio show it's
still kind of in the works so I'm sure
hopefully we'll have more information
the next time I come on the desk we'll
have settled yes my dear there's too
many things going on right now that I
haven't decided what is happening that's
there yeah and it's no need
yeah agency but there is there is there
was a falling out it was a big falling
out I'm not I'm not up on it but now
I'll have to be yep nope pay attention
it's pay attention pay attention so many
references on state show I'm like
someone really hit and everything today
totally anyways everyone have a
fantastic weekend we will be back on
Monday co-host TBD might be snitch might
be someone else uh and we will see you
then you can always follow me at rakia
problems and now I have to go home and
wait for my table to be delivered I'm so
excited and my groceries it's a big day
for me this is a huge day for you it's a
big day
oh my god na also I told you the story
before and now I have to tell it cuz
we've been talking about housewives the
whole time I went to a restaurant last
night yeah the waiter comes to our table
and he's like hi I'm Giovanni I'll be
your server tonight
you were like I was like what what did
you say I was like and I was like I have
to drink he said Giovanni anyways then
he comes back to take our order I'm like
by the way like did you say her name was
Giovanni and yes like yeah he's like
it's Italian I was like like I'm aware
he watched Real Housewives of New York
he was like having been my he's like I
used to watch but not anymore I'm like
has no one told you
Giovanni has no one screamed Giovanni at
you in the streets he was like no I
don't know what you're talking about I
was like oh my god like Instagram him
and then that way everyone in the
streets would have been like Giovanni I
really wanted to but like my phone it
was like dying and I was like I just
looked like a beast I wasn't gonna even
but anyway he was just so crazy there is
a server in Flatiron at Bo's kitchen and
bar named Giovanni go there and yell
screaming Giovanni yeah Giovanni by the
way I think is the best thing to come
well it's definitely the best in Kahana
this season like inside jokes why
totally um and I'm just like it's like
clue as much as Serena was definitely
heckling and being a bad friend like she
was being a good cast mate oh my good
worker I can't say Giovanni outside of
just yelling like I even if I saw him
I'd be like Java
I couldn't ever not say it that way no
so good I was at a show like a dinner
and a show thing and they were wearing
all these glitzy dresses and that's just
like Giovanni Giovanni so good ah oh my
stars bring people together always thank
you for tuning in thank you for being
here a strapping me thank you for being
a toaster you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram YouTube podcast we are now on
Spotify so yes hopefully we're in your
release radar today and we will see you
here on Monday good day good day
you